こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
みんな最近寒いと思わないかい？
そう！今日本はとても寒い寒気の冷気におされている
そう　だから俺は
服を買いたいと思っているんだ
今日は　服をたくさん買ってきたんだけども
服を買うことによって
いままでの
いらない服がどんどん出てくる訳なんすよ
家の中に服が多すぎる
服が多すぎるから
今日は服を
使わない服
今俺が生活する上で必要ないのない服を
全部売ります
実際ここらへん全部
全部、ああ全部　全部なくなったら嫌だなあ
全部なくなったら嫌だわ
どうすればいいんだろう
俺の、俺の中の全部の服を
まぁ全部売るよ
いや全部売ったら服がなくなる
生活していく上で必要ない服を全部売る
全部売ったら服がないんで
今日は　気持ち全部売ります
まぁ要するにね！
売るんすよ！
（ﾌﾞｯ）
汚っ
豆乳飲むまで待って
ここをさあ　なんか
服が多すぎて出ちゃうんだよね
いつも
あっ待ってめっちゃ豆乳飛び散った気がするわ
福袋で当たったんですけども
色が派手なので着ません
売ります
タートルネックは暑苦しいので着ません
これも売ろう、これも売ろう
これも売ります
え、待って…
普通に俺、これさ欲しい色
売る？
売ろう
着たい服を売るのか…
これも売りましょうｗ
まじか～
ていうか俺こういう服着てると思んすよ
実は三着持ってて
うち二着はもう売ります
これって売れるかな？
(ハリーポッターのヤツww)
売ってみるか
(売ってみよう)
これもね〜、あんまり使わなくな…売りましょう！
これも売ります
これも売りましょう
これもちょっと伸びちゃったんで売ります
これもさ、なんか春とかに普通に着れそうだよね
売ろう！
これも昔よく着てたんだよ
売ります！
こういうのも全部売ろう、もう。
これも売ろう
売りましょう
怒られるかな、6面ごめんね。
じゃ、一着とっとこう。も一個売ってみよう
宇宙人のスーツも売りましょう
これなんだろう？売りましょう
これドンキで買ったヤツなんだよ
ってこと？そんな露骨な
売ります！
これ後輩が置いてったズボンです
売りましょう
ヤバい、絶対に怒られる
白いズボンなんて履くことないよね
売りましょう
後輩のやつだ。置いてったやつが悪い。売ります。
これも実はイトーヨーカドーで買ったんだ。売ります
福袋のハズレです。売ります。
わー、懐かしい。
大学のサークルで使ってたポロシャツです。
売ります！
イギリスで買ったハワイアロハシャツ。売ります。
あ、昔よく履いてたやつ。わかる？
(わかる。サルエルのやつでしょ)
そう。
売ります！
割烹着は？割烹着は売れる？
割烹着も売ります！
え、でも、そしたら俺、料理できなくなるよ
料理用にとっておこう、これは。
いつ料理するかわからないから
季節的に海パンも売ります
昔さ、プージャー着てたんだけどさ、
上だけなくなっちゃって。下、売りま〜す。
これ高いよ。
なんかズボンもここら辺全部売っちゃいましょう
売ります！！
何これ？売ろう！
またなんかきた、アロハ系がさ。
これ、昔履いてたんだよ
あ〜、これ、なんか、ドンキー感すごいでしょ
お気に入りだけど売ります！
やべー、もうスカスカだ！
オレンジはちょっと着れないな、この年になると。
売ります
売りましょう
BITE
花柄のシャツ、ちょっとチャラいので売りましょう
こんなもんしょ。
これも売っていいかな？
売るか。売ろう。
痛っ！骨折れた！
これも売ろうか。売ります。
売ろう！
よしっ。はい！というわけで
今日売る服はこれだけです！！
はい。という訳でこれから
この服を全部売っていく訳なんですけども
何円だと？
50円？5千円？俺はね
1万2千円ぐらい
(そんなに？)
そこのみんなも考えてみてね
え、でも多分さ、売れないやつとかもあるんでしょ
となると、マジな方で言うと、多分
あ、すげぇ、ぴったり50着です。
では！早速！50着、売りに行こうと思います！
はい。という訳でやって参りました。
古着屋さんを売るお店があるので
そちらにちょっと今から全部売ってこようと思います
じゃ、行ってきます
服が50着あるので、審査に大体30分ほどかかるみたいなので
ちょっと休憩です
やったー！よっしゃー！
YES！YES！YES！
はい。という訳で、売ってきたんですけども
(ドラムロール)
え？高くない？
千円の服が1枚、300円の服が8枚、
500円の服が1枚、100円の服が16枚、
その他全部含めて500円
という訳で6000円になりました
服ってやっぱり溜まっちゃうんで、どんどん売った方が
いいと思うんスよ。
売って、6000円にしたので
今晩は焼肉です！
チーズバーガー1つ、爽健美茶S1つ、以上で。
(はい。かしこまりました。)